[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt jetzt kommt wieder die warme sommer
kommt und ich habe es immer richtig
gerne wenn ich kräuter auf der terrasse
habe vor einigen jahren habe ich euch
schon mal mein kräuter hochbeet gezeigt
dass es hier im hintergrund da kriegst
auch bald wieder etwas dass kräuter
hochburg ist natürlich nur was für leute
die eben auch viel platz auf der
terrasse oder im garten haben und man
muss auch sagen die anschaffung ist
nicht ganz so günstig deswegen gibt es
heute eine durch idee eine idee zum
selber nachmachen wirklich für wenig
geld und das könnt ihr ganz einfach
selber basteln ich habe hier blumen ja
blumenkübel oder kräuter kübel gebastelt
die habe ich gebaut aus holz und dann
noch schön lackiert damit der wind und
wetterfest sind und ich zeige ich jetzt
einfach mal was ihr dafür für werkzeug
benötigt für zutaten sozusagen und dann
geht's los im baumarkt verschiedene
bretter besorgt und die haben alle die
stärke von 23 mm
ich brauche jetzt zuerst wenn man viel
lange bretter ein mittelstück zwei
kleine bretter zwei außenteile vier
beine die sind 38 mm stark einen
akkuschrauber eine stichsäge ich brauche
spax schrauben aus edelstahl in 6 cm und
spax schrauben in edelstahl in 4 cm
länge etwas acryl bund laut auf
wasserbasis da könnt ihr matt oder
glänzend verwenden eine fahrbahn
farbrollen und pinsel eine
wachstumsstarke und einen tanker
ich habe das ganze baumaterial einfach
im baumarkt besorgt und habe da fürchten
holz genommen und bei dem holz ist ganz
wichtig dass man hier diese jahresringe
seht und wenn die hier stehen so wie
hier ist es wirklich ein wunderbares
holz und das könnt ihr auf jeden fall
nehmen lassen auf jeden fall des falls
schon im baumarkt zu sehen dann habt ihr
zuhause nicht die arbeit und könnt nach
heim wirklich gleich loslegen
jetzt wird zuerst einmal der boden der
wanne hergestellt dafür nehme ich jetzt
die zwei langen brettern und das
mittelstück und die werden jetzt gleich
verbunden
allerdings muss ich vorher was zurecht
segen und dafür nehme ich jetzt einmal
den fuß legt den hier drauf schön bündig
in die ecke und dann könnt ihr mit einem
bleistift hier entlang zeichnen
in den teilen hier weg segen
das ganze natürlich auch hier drüben
[Musik]
und auf der anderen seite
jetzt kann ich die ecken mit der
stichsäge ganz einfach ausschneiden und
am besten ist es wenn ihr direkt beim
saugut unterhaltet dann entsteht gar
keinen dreck
jetzt kann ich die drei blätter
verbinden und dafür sind die kleinen
helfer dann lege ich jetzt hier mit ich
drauf und brauche dann pro holzstück
etwa sechs schrauben und die dürfen
jetzt nicht so lange sein
daher können dass sich hieraus einmal
hinlegen und einfach mal schauen
wir dürfen natürlich nicht durchs holz
durch da hätte man jetzt auch
edelstahlschrauben nehmen müssen die
habe ich in berlin aber nicht gefunden
im baumarkt ist jetzt hier nicht schlimm
weil es einfach auch die unterseite
gleich sein wird also jetzt hier oben 2
in der mitte und hier unten noch zwei
schrauben rein born ihr könnt das ganze
entweder vor bauen oder direkt rein
schrauben und jetzt nur darauf achten
nicht so weit an den rand zu gehen damit
es soll es mit splittert sondern eher so
ein bisschen in die mitte
und nach der ersten scheibe nämlich die
diagonale hier drüben
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus und jetzt
ist die unterseite auch schon fertig und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie das ganze
zusammen gebaut wird
hier kommen dann noch die zwei
seitenteile dran und die zwei kurzen
hier und da und da kommen jetzt noch die
füße reiben da habe ich das ganze
herausgesägt und zwar sieht das dann so
aus
zwar kommt der fonds das schön stabil
ist und das ganze nicht so wackelt hier
rein mit hier verschraubt und hier
kommen noch die seite rein und dann
steht es wirklich schön stabil
und da ich jetzt keine tolle werkbank
habe sondern nur einen ästhetisch
schraube ich jetzt so erst einmal die
füße an das äußere brettern und legst du
hier drauf damit schön gerade legt kann
ich das hier einfach zur unterstützung
darunter legen und so sieht man dann
auch von außen die schrauben nicht und
hier sind ganz wichtig längere schrauben
zu nehmen aber nur so lange dass sie
eben nicht auf der anderen seite raus
kommen
[Musik]
und so mache ich jetzt auch den zweiten
jetzt kann alles verschraubt werden da
ist es am einfachsten wenn noch jemand
dabei habt und zwar nehme ich einen teil
mit den beinchen dran
jetzt kommt die platte natürlich mit den
zwei hölzern nach unten zeigen und es
kommt ihr hier bündig mit dem rand also
hier und muss das ganze bündig
abschließen damit ich auch ein bisschen
höher hat für die erde ist nämlich einen
seitenteil und legt es hier dran und
kann jetzt hier aus und schon mal die
schrauben rein worden und hier sind
diese spax schrauben act ideal denn die
ziehen das holz richtig schön zusammen
ohne dass ich vor bauen muss wer das
ganze aber nicht so aus der hand und so
spontan hinbekommt er kann das ganze
auch vorbei und dann geht es zusammen
schrauben bisschen einfach die obere
schraube mache ich jetzt ein bisschen
locker jetzt ist nämlich die seite die
schöne fest und ich kann hier die andere
seite dran legen
[Musik]
und jetzt sitzt hier bündig und ich kann
die schrauben wieder rein drehen
[Musik]
und hier ist es im prinzip nur wichtig
dass man zwei schrauben mindestens hier
oben rein setzt damit die durch das
oberholz gehen und zwei schrauben
mindestens hier rein also weiter unten
damit die durchs bein gehen und es
einfach stabilisieren und ich brauche es
jetzt hier ganz kurz vor so geht es ein
bisschen einfacher
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles schon mal ziemlich
stabil wichtig ist immer nur das hier
alles schön bündig ist und natürlich
auch unten und wer möchte kann jetzt
hier um dieses teil noch zu verstärken
hieraus noch zwei schrauben rein born
[Musik]
fertig jetzt steht schon mal das
grundgerüst und es kann gleich angst im
magen gehen
ich zeige es euch hier einmal so richtig
schön stabilen tisch hier innen ganz
viel platz für viel erde und viele
pflanzen und ich habe jetzt hier bei dem
holzhaus genommen das heißt sägerei und
dieses nimmt bis zu viermal mehr farbe
auf als gehobene des holzes und dafür
habe ich jetzt die acrylfarbe einmal in
mathe und einmal in glänzend wichtig ist
nur dass sie auf wasserbasis ist und das
ganze werde ich jetzt draußen auf der
terrasse weil wir gerade schönes wetter
haben anmalen und mit hilfe von meiner
fahrplan meinen rollen und vielleicht
brauche ich auf dem kind das sich schwer
[Musik]
so fertig ich habe jetzt alles schön
gestrichen hier innen die wanne lasse
ich aus da kommt ja sowieso die folie
rein aber auch die unterseite ist
gestrichen und ich las es das gestell
ist so einfach mal trocknen streich noch
einmal drüber
ich möchte aber nicht so oft darüber
streichen denn ich möchte diese
holzstruktur auch noch sehen
ich habe das ganze auch vor heimisch
geschliffen einfach weil ich es schön
finden draußen darf so ein bisschen ja
so ein bisschen rustikaler wirken das
ganze lasse ich dann ganz trocknen und
dann können wir nämlich schon die folie
dran tackern und das ganze schön
bepflanzten
[Musik]
meine zwei kräuterbeete sind jetzt
getrocknet und jetzt werden sie innen
ausgelegt damit einfach kein wasser
durchdringt und das holz kaputt macht
daher habe ich hier jetzt eine
wachstumsstarke genommen die bekommen
die auch in jedem baumarkt die sind auch
super günstig farbe ist im prinzip egal
da später sowieso erde reinkommt die
müsste dann ganz grob zu schneiden und
dann einfach mit dem tucker befestigen
geht wirklich super einfach ein bisschen
knifflig sind die ecken aber wenn dir
ein bisschen zurecht legt und dann brand
hat ist das auch ein kinderspiel
und jetzt kann ich mein bett schon
bepflanzen und ich nehme ich etwas
anzuchterde für meine kräuter weil so
die kräuter am besten wachsen
ich bin nicht so stark deswegen muss ich
das so machen auch wenn der murat dabei
wird er hat mir jetzt einfach den sack
hochgehoben und hat mir das schön rein
führen können egal ich habe ich jetzt
eine schöne auswahl an kräutern und ich
nehme einfach die im topf weil die sich
sehr schnell vermehren
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch samen säen
und das ganze selbst großziehen
ich nehme zwar erstmal basilikum was
hier nicht mit rein kommt ist die münze
da habe ich nämlich gelernt aus meinem
großen kreuzer hofft dass die sich
wirklich vermehrt wie unkraut und dann
einfach alles andere über wächst
sozusagen und die minze kommt dann ins
große kräuter hochbeet und einfach so
eine kleine mulde reihen und direkt mit
der erde reihen den basilikum nämlich
ein bisschen auseinander damit er schön
wächst und viel platz hat ihr könnt hier
aber auch zum beispiel blumen pflanzen
das ist auch wunderschön und dieses
kräuterbeet für alles benutzen
[Musik]
ich habe ziehe die kräutertöpfe bereits
gibt's land ich hab's dir übrigens
zweimal pflanzen müssen weil nach dem
ersten pflanzen was ihr gesehen habt kam
noch einmal der winter der frost und
schnee dann war alles kaputt
jetzt habe ich nochmal alles
eingepflanzt hier nochmal thymian gesät
und bisschen schnittlauch und salbei aus
der türkei noch einen mini basilikum der
ist auch richtig schön und ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
macht doch einfach diese idee man nach
auf meinem blog könnt ihr nochmal die
genauen maße nachlesen wir sehen uns
wieder beim nächsten mal und schreibt
mir einfach welche drittes selbst gerne
als nächstes sehen würde also bis bald
und viel spaß dabei
[Musik]